selon les militaires donc l'application
du plan clément marot n'est pas à mettre
en cause mais du côté des contrôleurs
civils de la navigation aérienne et du
côté des pilotes dont la plupart je vous
le rappelle ont décidé aujourd'hui de ne
plus voler sous le contrôle des
militaires ont fait valoir que ce
système de remplacement est insuffisant
pour ce qui concerne la sécurité
non pas que la compétence des militaires
soit en cause mais les navigants estime
que la prise en charge du trafic
commercial est un travail totalement
différent de celui que les militaires
sont amenés exécuté avec l'armée de
l'air dès la prise en charge par mme hay
nahda des trafiquants question à savoir
le coronado qui arrivait de bilbao
direction nantes pour aller à londres
après et le dc-9 qui lui venait de palma
par cognac nom et londres après ils
étaient déjà apparents ici qu'un risque
de collision existait à la verticale de
nantes puisque les deux appareils
avaient passé une estime et c'est à dire
une heure de passage estimé à la
verticale de nantes sensiblement
identique à l'année l'heure est à la
même attitude
exactement donc ici il fallait faire
quelque chose
l'action a été initiée tardivement
lorsque les avions commencé à entrer
dans la limite de porter radio de mahina
radars et au passage ou dit aussi limite
de porter la barre parce qu'ils
n'étaient plus emporté radar ici du
moins de marina radars
quand on accuse le pilote du coronado de
ne pas avoir exécuté lamaneurs de
ralentissements dont il a accusé
réception
je trouve pour le moins sept accusations
hâtives
ici si le contrôle avait précédé les
avions et bien observant des difficultés
de communication avec le coronado
logiquement il fallait agir sur
l'appareil
ici le décideur avec lequel
les communications sont réputés avoir
été très bonne tout le temps or cet
appareil a continué comme prévu sans
aucune altération sans aucune
notification du moins on nous le dit
actuellement nous avions eu l'occasion
au moment de la mise en place du plan
clément marot de souligner que le métier
de contrôleur militaire n'était pas le
même que le métier de contrôleur civil
veut dire que tu as un contrôleur
militaires recrutés chez nous ont besoin
d'une formation qui durait pas pour
autant de temps que la nôtre et que par
conséquent il était toujours possible de
prendre un peu de trafic mais quand on
on tombait dans les débordements très
sérieux et des risques graves de l'or
que on parlait de 70 à 100 % du trafic
normal
ces jours derniers les informations vous
ont laissé penser laisser à penser que
d'autres catastrophes ont été évités de
peu
oui nous avons récupéré des
renseignements parce que les contrôleurs
sont très intéressés et très passionné
par ce qui se passe pour l'instant et
certains d'entre eux ont des postes qui
leur permettent d'écouter des fréquences
ils ont récupéré effectivement des
risques assez graves dont l'un
pratiquement en même temps que la
collision qui s'est produit du côté de
nevers et un autre du côté de troyes
disons que plus on augmente au trafic
puis le problème devient difficile et si
les gens ne sont point d'entrée n'est
bien sûr plus les risques deviennent
importants